there's no question that kudans is
considered one of the best tekken
players to ever play the game
even after taking a break in tekken 6
kurenze showed no signs of rust and
managed to come back in the latter days
of tag two
and of course in tekken 7 he would show
off his godlike skills with devil gin
and would deliver one of the best
performances in tekken tournament
history
[Music]
[Applause]
claiming the title of the first player
to win the tekken world tour tournament
in 2017.
this video is a short compilation of
kuden's looking like he activated
godlike mode in tournament matches my
name is drew and you're watching ochoto
tv be cool the laser almost hit almost
okay backing up jimmy oh he got it
[Music]
i thought he knew how to get out of the
burning knucklebomb he didn't expect he
would go for it again
burning knuckleball oh he went for a
chunk
gets crouched yeah he knew that he knew
that option there for the back throw
attempt
but he was able to get him
into the hell he's not prepared as
you're seeing here the pinnacle of
korean movement here with devil dude
heaven's gate coming down from above oh
god it's the duck it might be that is
what might be alive yes he's alive oh
heartbreaking
trying to create some kind of
opportunity another hell
[Music]
oh my god
you have to be so brave i mean you can
consider all of the options for kicks
[Music]
this is pivotal this is gonna be the
biggest round rodeo
[Music]
[Music]
oh here we go the pressure you see the
jacks now but again continuing
[Music]
damaged
[Music]
oh
right now just staying back doesn't want
to touch
oh
[Music]
oh
again
you knew that he was too low there
threatening
with the kudos
again
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hell sleep against the wall
there he wanted another one
did you like that
[Music]
just a regular god business
this is terrifying to play again
oh
sir
yo kudos just shut everyone up here
everyone's making it to shadow but now
it's all cool i'm having flashbacks and
flashbacks of t5 yo he's like yo i'm
warmed up bro
hit the bike another regular guy is this
enough to kill him
takes it with the perfect
[Music]
yep foreshadowing second world tour
presented by company's asia finals
last fact of the day
oh my god start it off
hey man your shoes are untied no they're
not huh
and he gets the wall depression
the crowd is going nuts i'm gonna start
throwing my head back after losing in
our winners final oh my gosh that
godfist electricity all around
half-life already going went for the
down laser buck and punished kudos is
alive ladies and gentlemen the crowd is
cheering with every single hit that
definitely lands again you got to watch
your toes see that's why it keeps
getting hit the robot oh wow look at
this pressure i'ma hold the mic closer
to my face
just so you guys know just how important
this match is if you're going to break
anything break the mic
electric
nice combo there from budapest
is on the ropes right now he needs to do
something thunder godfish gets the
follow-up what's gonna happen going for
the damage here it goes for the mid a
4-4
oh
one two two down back to
anything's gonna do it right now when
lancer what'd you get
oh my god this is the final hit 15
seconds left that kudos takes it ladies
and gentlemen he takes out each age of
majors kudos secures himself a spot in
the second world tour finals man what is
that make some noise ladies and
gentlemen what a set and who does first
[Music]
man waiting for this opportunity that's
the thing is you flinch you might die
yeah
you don't take one little mistake look
at this time again
oh he got him
that might be it
oh look at that is that going to hit the
timings oh my gosh
[Music]
wow
you know this must be internally for a
few hands must be such a huge
accomplishment
[Music]
oh my gosh again
away at his ankles and they're landing
they're working but how he's going to
work from here yeah oh no
the damage is going to be huge here he's
got the rage drive
yep he's going to use it big damage not
quite oh
he might not oh my god it didn't even
touch him
he went over it wow
unbelievable okay
he's still in there and there's the
counter hit another missed electric
laser scraper
heals the deal despite all those
mistakes
this is it
oh my god did you thought he couldn't do
it
that's where he was that's where i left
him it was in my cargo pocket oh man
yeah he gets it
two cars that's a big chunk oh he went
for the slide
oh my god down here this time going for
the mids now all the side steps here
from the movie
so close
that's not what you want to happen just
jump this is an outrage
oh the red darts is that gonna do it oh
it's killed off
i can't believe it i can't oh my
he hug me right now i
cannot believe my eyes
[Music]
foreign
yes
[Music]
[Music]
back turn hopkins let me get another
combo check this one out
slash kick wall pressure oh he tried to
power crush he's trying to 3-0
i don't think he's one round away from
being one match away from the reset wow
wow
[Music]
yeah point blank too
okay oh boy
and that is always a common factor
[Music]
he's gonna need such a miracle
[Music]
oh my god he got him it's not much more
of a miracle left oh no i don't think he
hit a button at all oh
he got him i can't believe it hold on i
mean he got so many miracle comebacks
fishing for that downpour too
no time what's he gonna do
hey you can think he's going to have to
go low there's no time left
oh [ __ ] stop stop are you serious oh my
god dude is crazy
my god
[Applause]
can i yell 2-0 after this one yes you
can oh my gosh he's gonna get it he's
gonna get it
oh my gosh oh
man
wow the pop off oh you can see it goes
while standing one plus two gets the
follow up he's gonna push to the wall
saint is trying to tie him he dropped it
yeah he hesitated
he's trying to tie this up we're by the
watermelons oh no and here comes a big
god [ __ ] electricity very important
combo here
oh no
the rage oh this is big this one does so
much still huge so huge
is
thanks for watching be sure to subscribe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you